well we have another disastrous example
of the repercussions of these horrifying
anti-abortion laws many of which were
triggered into existence
uh by the supreme court overturning roe
v wade we go to texas in texas a
youtuber
was forced to carry
her dead fetus
for two weeks after a miscarriage due to
the anti-abortion law
the same surgical procedure used to
treat a miscarriage is also used for
terminating pregnancies the new texas
anti-abortion laws have doctors nervous
to perform procedures for miscarriages
forcing this woman to carry her dead
fetus in her womb for two weeks
another example we've now seen women
going without emergency care
we've seen women going without cancer
care and now women forced to have their
dead fetus in the womb
for weeks due to these anti-abortion
laws and we're supposed to believe this
is all pro-life
beauty youtuber forced to carry dead
fetus for two weeks after miscarriage
due to abortion ban
i get so angry that i was treated this
way because of laws that were passed by
men
who have never been pregnant and never
will be says marlena stell founder of
makeup geek cosmetics
marlena stell recently spoke to cnn
about her gut-wrenching miscarriage and
how she was forced to carry her dead
fetus for two weeks when a doctor
refused to provide medical intervention
due to the texas anti-abortion law
stella is a beauty youtuber and founder
of the cosmetics company makeup geek she
initially explained in a video last year
she and her husband were thrilled to
learn of the pregnancy noting that an
ultrasound at seven weeks was normal
however another ultrasound two weeks
later revealed stell suffered a
pregnancy loss the doctor says there's
no heartbeat there's no viable pregnancy
following the news she asked for a dnc
which is a surgery to remove the fetus
also used to abort a living fetus this
was not a living fetus in order to avoid
infection or long-term health issues the
doctor said because of the new law
that's passed here you have to schedule
another ultrasound to verify that this
pregnancy is not valid before we can
give you any sort of medical
intervention
dr lillian shapiro an atlanta-based ob
gyn said to cnn carrying a dead fetus
can quickly become dangerous for the
mother
right but they're pro-life guys
they're all pro-life
so consider this situation imagine how
horrendous this is
it's not just
psychologically
disastrous walking around
with parts of a dead fetus inside you
that you're not allowed to have treated
the psychological impact but it's also
physically extremely dangerous and these
women are being is it too much to say
they're being tortured by republican law
doesn't seem like too much to say to me
she wanted to carry this pregnancy to
term and deliver it she didn't you know
the right loves to have this
almost at this point cliche borderline
satirical view of how women decide to
get an abortion
well
it's month seven it's month eight it's
month nine i don't know i guess i don't
want it give me an abortion please that
that's an absurd fantasy but this is not
even someone who didn't want the
pregnancy this is someone who did she
wanted to carry the pregnancy to term
and deliver she miscarried and she was
denied treatment
because the treatment is the quote same
as that for surgical abortions
this situation uh ectopic pregnancy
we're also seeing it's like the entire
political party
never even took basic biology in high
school so we have
you know i i at this point we're two
weeks in guys since i told you
doctors are sounding the alarm
and saying
they may be denying treatment to women
for fear
of being prosecuted for fear of not only
law enforcement
but politicians coming after them and
when i did that first story i got emails
from people saying david you're dealing
in hypotheticals david none of these
things are happening the hypothetical
about a 12 year old pregnant girl it's
merely hypothetical and then we got a 10
year old pregnant girl who had to leave
ohio and go to indiana to get an
abortion oh well now the issue's
different it's a fake story oh no but
the alleged rapist is an undocumented
alien so now it's a real story but
that's the only important part pathetic
and hear same thing oh no
just because a group of doctors warned
that this might happen doesn't mean it's
happening well now it is
now it is here is a specific woman
who was told
yes the fetus has died
but because of the law the anti-abortion
law you've got to walk around for two
weeks this way before we can do anything
and there's going to be more of it
and the next layer in this
is
this is getting so absurd that even the
republicans can't defend it so the new
thing they're doing is they're playing
semantic games and the the semantic
games that they're playing as they're
saying well
this procedure done
when there has already been a
miscarriage is not technically an
abortion and they're trying to hide
behind that as if this isn't the natural
effect of the law that they pass which
of course it is
horrifying
pathetic
and extremely damaging to the women
physically and psychologically and to
their families it's not just about the
women
um
what will we have for you tomorrow
i don't even want to know quite frankly
i'm sure it'll be horrible
we have learned about the forthcoming
testimony of the former deputy national
security adviser to donald trump in
front of the january 6 trump riot
committee this is a really really big
deal now i know many of you are
wondering the same thing i'm wondering
is this
witness the one that donald trump tried
to call
in order to tamper with to influence his
forthcoming testimony we don't know the
answer to that but we'll get back to
that in a moment
first on cnn former trump national
security council official will testify
at thursday's january 16th hearing this
is not like some intern or coffee boy
this is the deputy national security
adviser and in fact it's widely known
that
the deputy national security adviser is
often the person really running the
national security council who's
uh who becomes sort of the intermediary
between the security council the
national security adviser and everybody
else
matthew pottinger is his name he served
on trump's nsc before resigning in the
aftermath of january 6th there is a
prime time hearing on thursday night my
intent like joe biden says my intent is
to cover it baby permitting uh he will
testify publicly at thursday's prime
time hearing
pottinger is slated to appear alongside
former trump white house aide sarah
matthews who is believed to have quite
uh
extreme or uh nuanced nuance both really
insights into the trump white house cnn
previously reported that matthews who
was deputy press secretary until
resigning shortly after january 6 was
expected to testify publicly when she
resigned matthew said she was honored to
serve in trump's administration but was
deeply disturbed by what she saw
pottinger trump's deputy national
security adviser stepped down
in response to trump's reaction to his
supporters breaching the u s capital
he told people there was very little for
him to consider a spokesperson for the
committee has declined to comment
we are going to see
some very very real stuff on what is
right now the final
scheduled hearing from the january 6
trump riot committee
the headline here
dramatically understates who matthew
pottinger was it simply says national
security council official as i said
we're talking here about the principal
deputy national security advisor
front row
to everything that was going on in that
extremely high level organization group
committee whatever you want to call it
now
there are a few things that are going to
happen
first of all is the question
did donald trump call you to try to talk
to you about this testimony and we don't
know the answer to that we know pearl is
cheney that donald trump tried to call
some forthcoming witness it may be
matthew pottinger it may not hopefully
members of congress on the committee ask
that question on thursday and we will
get an answer number two
trump will probably attempt the typical
smear campaign that he does when people
testify
when people become disgruntled or
whatever term you want to use
he will say this was not a particularly
good employee he wasn't particularly
bright and on and on and on and of
course there are two different issues
with that number one trump says it about
everyone who has something negative to
say about him that's number one and of
course number two
trump ran on i know how to hire people
and the best people i can tell who's
good and who's not good i can tell who's
smart not smart good at a job
and
individual after individual who is left
we're talking about rex tillerson we're
talking about john bolton it's a very
long list cassidy hutchinson more
recently in terms of the
witnesses in this committee trump
attacks them and says they weren't smart
and all these different things well you
hired him
you hired him and you said you're hiring
was really the best thing that you did
now
what happens after the committee is done
we don't know the answer to that there
is
you know the the
the question continues to be
will merrick garland and the department
of justice charge anyone based on what
was learned in this committee we don't
know the answer to that i think that
there are two different ways to look at
this one if you came to me and you said
sir
obama right uh do you have any reason to
believe merrick garland plans to charge
people based on this committee i would
say no i have no reason to believe that
the only thing we've heard is the doj is
paying attention to the committee
hearings okay but we have seen no
evidence that garland is willing to do
what would be admittedly very difficult
in charging some of these former
officials on the other hand
it is true
that it takes a while to put cases
together and it's completely plausible
realistic
that if indeed the doj learned about
possible crimes from watching the
committee hearings and they started
investigations only when the committee
hearings took place
it's completely plausible that it would
take a couple to a few months to put
together a case and investigate whether
there are charges they're confident they
could get a guilty verdict on so the
timing is not really the issue for me
it's reasonable that they hear about
something in june
and they might charge in october or
november or december that the timeline
isn't really the concern the concern is
it seems as though there's kind of a
meekness
with regard to even really seriously
considering charging these people
up to and including donald trump and
that's what makes me wonder
is it just they're putting cases
together or is it there's no real
interest and willingness to actually do
what would be very difficult but would
be the right thing to do if that's where
the facts point let me know what you
think is taking place you can find me on
twitter at dpakman i also want to remind
you next tuesday one week from today is
the next david pakman show viewer town
hall these are you know we do the calls
on the friday show but we don't have
that much time for it usually it's about
20 25 minutes
next tuesday 6 p.m eastern time 3 p.m
pacific u.s of course for our friends in
europe it'll be you know like midnight
um we're going to be opening up the
phone lines and we will be taking an
hour to an hour and a half of calls
everybody is welcome to call in if you
want to watch here's the sort of key
thing it will only air
on the pacman live youtube channel it
won't be on the main youtube channel the
one with the roughly 1.5 million
subscribers it won't be on twitch it
won't be on facebook we will only be
streaming the town hall on the pacman
live youtube channel everybody can watch
everybody can participate and yes if you
are a website member you will get
priority access to participate in the
town hall all right more about that as
we get closer
don't forget that the best way to
support the david pakman show is by
becoming a member which gives you access
to the daily bonus show the regular show
with no commercials you also get access
to our entire archive of every episode
dating back
a really long time and plenty of other
awesome membership perks go to
joinpakman.com
and use the coupon code better21 for a
huge discount join pacman.com
the david pakman show is made possible
by viewers and listeners through the
membership program you can sign up at
joinpackman.com we do an extra show
every day for our members we also offer
a commercial free audio feed and a
commercial free video feed of the show
every single day and it's also available
roughly five to six hours
a lawsuit against all machines that's
weird where did that come from well
listen you will not be sued for taking
advantage of membership and
and you can use the coupon code
bigvoting22
at
joinpakman.com wow mike pillow out of
nowhere okay the continued comedy of
errors that also has a major
humanitarian death toll right so we
don't want to merely call it a comedy of
errors
russia has apparently shot down their
own 36 million dollar bomber jet an
airplane um this is according to ukraine
there's a newsweek article explaining it
a 36 million russian su-34 bomber was
reportedly shot down by russia's own
forces over ukraine's eastern luhansk
region according to ukrainian media
outlets yesterday
the jet was reportedly down near
alchefska city in the luhansk region
this is where the war is currently
focused and all chess is currently under
the occupation of moscow-backed
separatist forces
a video and images shared by the
strategic command of the armed forces of
ukraine on the telegram messaging app
appear to show the charge remains of a
russian su-34 fighter bomber now there
is
there's some confusion about this
because there were reports that the
picture of a non-destroyed bomber is not
actually of the su-34
and uh there's some debate as to whether
the reporting is showing the right
planes or whether the reporting is
describing the right planes it appears
to be
that it is an su-34
but that some of the images are not
actually of that plane which makes you
wonder
uh you know it makes you under a number
of different things although i believe
that this picture that i'm showing you
is of the
su-34 you know um these types of
accidents actually do happen in in war
it's not
the strangest thing and when you get
over a hundred days right i mean we're
into month four at this point of a war
where
neither side is
dramatically well organized when it
comes to air warfare uh there are s
there's similar looking equipment on
both sides
it's not the most unheard of thing but
at the same time we don't currently know
um exactly how this plane was shot down
was it shot down by ground fire you
would think that any air defense
missiles
would be checking for identifiers where
planes have an identifier i guess if the
identifier system malfunctioned or if it
didn't work
maybe russian troops thought this was an
enemy bomber and they shot it down as a
result but it's a good opportunity to
kind of zoom out and talk about what's
going on in ukraine bigger picture and
it's not good
um and i've i've spoken with you before
about how
the stories that make good stories for
corporate media
are stories that have a relatively
clearly defined beginning middle and end
and if you think back to coverage of the
iraq war in 2003 and the lead-up you had
making the case for the war that was a
clear like a pre-war
phase
uh and that included the testimony
before
congress which included faulty uh
intelligence as we now know it included
george w bush making the case and
ultimately george w bush announcing the
start of the war and then it went to
missiles and the entire thing
the actual meet of the war coverage and
then you had the mission accomplished
banner and even though after that is
when most of the civilian and and uh um
uh military casualties took place after
the mission accomplished moment
there was less coverage of the war as an
event that is ongoing it became
background at that point and this is why
and i know many of you have heard this
already but i think it's important to
unders understand and for me to explain
how a lot of these corporate media
narratives kind of work uh if you have a
story like
hunger deaths among african children
which is sort of like your prototypical
um
tragedy in the sense that it's always
going on and there's a question of well
when and how is it covered
it's ongoing
and this is why
the constant deaths of children
from hunger in africa
don't get the attention in western media
as one or two people
uh killed in a school shooting as an
example doesn't mean any of the deaths
are any more or less tragic
and in terms of preventability that's a
whole other conversation to have as well
but
with the
invasion of ukraine by russia
we are now kind of in that middle phase
and that middle phase can be very very
long and at this point you can make the
case that nothing new is happening now
every time bombs are dropped
every time an apartment building is
bombed every time people are killed
those are new things that are happening
it's just as tragic when person 100 and
1000 is killed as when it's person
number one
but the stories start to blend and
people start to say well weren't they
already in the luhansk region was this
the donetsk or what what was it didn't i
think the the the infirmary
or the nursery was already bombed was oh
this one's in a different place and so
the coverage we're seeing in corporate
media starts to reflect that
prototypical prototypical for
independent shows like ours the
challenge becomes
how to continue covering it
um
given that
the resources of shows like ours to have
people on the ground are dramatically
more limited and so to a certain degree
we we are
reacting to
the coverage that is taking place which
uh is certainly uh diminished at this
point but the latest news is that that
this is sort of the individual element
of the story
russia apparently shooting down one of
its own fighter jets and uh you know we
could we could call it a comedy of
errors and stop there if it weren't so
tragic
the fox news
near satire i mean it it seems like
satire about gas prices declining
is taking on
even more uh comedic proportions
the new headline on fox news during a
segment about gas prices which are down
and i'm going to talk to you about that
is
white house takes a victory lap
on a 50 cent decline in gas prices
and fox reporters and commentators
bemoaning and criticizing joe biden what
now biden's bragging for the fact that
gas prices are down well listen if you
blame him for gas prices being up
wouldn't you give him some credit for
gas prices being down and this is a
circular
circular firing squad of sorts as old as
certainly this show has been going on if
you've got a democratic president and
you're a democrat and gas prices go up
you often say there's no connection
between the president and gas prices but
if it's a republican you say oh the
republicans to blame for the gas price
is going up flip it gas prices go down
and you don't like the guy or gal in the
oval office well uh you don't give them
any credit for that however if your guy
or gal is in the oval office and gas
prices go down you go look at the great
job that they're doing now i don't do
that
i respect you too much
to play that game with you
i've regularly told you
presidents have almost nothing to do
with gas prices and we will get to that
but that being said
it cannot be denied
that gas prices are down and they're
down quite significantly if you actually
take a look after peaking at dollars and
two cents per gallon nationally
uh they are now down to 449. that is
indeed a 53 decline it's about 11
percent i mean gas is still high there's
no denying that but it is a significant
significant decline
what can presidents do
what can presidents do to impact gas
prices there's basically three things
one is invade a country that has a bunch
of oil
and essentially take it steal it and use
it and then use that to introduce it
into the market and it presumably based
on the laws of supply and demand should
reduce gas prices at least to some
degree number two do a gas tax holiday
gas tax holiday will temporarily
lower the price of gas and people can
stock up on gas if they want if there's
no limit on how much you can buy and
number three is tap into the strategic
petroleum reserve strategic petroleum
reserve
can
depending on who you ask lower gas
prices temporarily between 12 and 18
cents per gallon some people say up to
25
slightly different numbers depending on
who you ask those are the things a
president can do but if you're fox news
and you've been playing the gas prices
up is all thanks to biden to some degree
don't you have to give him credit credit
for prices going down and just imagine
the fox news editorial meeting okay
we can't talk about rising gas prices
anymore any other ideas how about this
let's slam that they're coming down too
quickly
that it will hurt gas stations
and that joe biden is being
braggadocious about it that's what they
did that's what they're doing when fox
news starts complaining that the gas
prices are falling too quickly you start
to know something's wrong and uh it
wouldn't surprise me to see a headline
like
did joe biden lower gas prices
to distract
from hunter biden's laptop i haven't
seen that
that's imaginary
but it wouldn't surprise me what we did
see and i'm not joking by the way about
the gas stations thing we looked at this
last week here's fox news bemoaning
lower gas prices because mom and pop gas
stations could be hurt let's uh want him
to run again
and the rest probably don't
that is stunning by the way on gas
prices i found it curious i was at a
lacrosse tournament up in wilmington
delaware over the weekend in delaware
and northern maryland regular gas is
about anywhere from 455 to 480 a gallon
so the price is beginning to creep back
down it is it is and the point was made
over the weekend i believe it's a wall
street journal that gas prices are
actually coming back down historically
faster with the price of oil than usual
oh they might be coming down too quickly
this goes to show you what an incredible
risk uh reward calculation has to happen
on the part of those small independently
owned most of them mom-and-pop gas
stations it's a struggle for all of them
now that's not really true and there's a
bunch of different things that go into
that just to quickly refresh your memory
without going back into it
first gas stations make very little off
of selling gas that's number one and
number two
their margin is very similar whether gas
prices are high or low right i mean if
your markup is on average seven to ten
cents per gallon if you sell it for five
bucks a gallon you make seven to ten
cents per gallon and if you sell it for
two bucks a gallon you make seven to ten
cents per gallon
sometimes high gas prices are actually
bad for gas stations when gas prices are
really high you will sometimes see gas
stations eat a little bit of the cost
they will accept if everybody's
accepting a seven cent profit you might
see a gas station go you know what we
make more from the slurpees and the ring
dings and the honey buns and the entire
thing
so
we're going to just eat some of this
price increase to be the cheapest in the
area we'll just accept like a two cent
profit on gas or maybe just no profit to
get people in buying the higher uh
higher margin stuff so not only are
higher gas prices not necessarily good
for local gas stations sometimes they're
actually bad but fox news won't tell you
that they'll just say oh no what is joe
biden irresponsible for so quickly
lowering gas prices but it's also
nothing that he did but if he did it
then it's bad give me a break guys we'll
have this clip on our instagram you can
find us on instagram at david pakman
show see you there
if you value what we do at the david
pakman show remember to support us on
patreon go to patreon.com
davidpakmanshow where you can get access
to behind the scenes videos the daily
bonus show the commercial free daily
show as well as special discounts on
merch including hats hoodies mugs and
t-shirts you can support the show for as
little as two dollars a month check it
out at patreon.com david pakman show
well according to the anti-a choice
right
if abortions are bad then adoption is
good and in fact you have all these
couples and people with pictures where
they say we will adopt your kids don't
abort we will adopt your kids so it's
all good right and abortion
increased adoption everybody's happy
well not so fast
a radical repugnant republic
congresswoman marjorie taylor green
is now saying that non-biological
parents are dangerous to children they
are dangerous to children well hold on
abortion's bad
but adoption is also bad that doesn't
make a lot of sense
but that's what she's saying
lgbtq nation reporting marjorie taylor
green calls non-biological parents a
danger to children
she doesn't like fake mom and fake dad
does she have a problem with adoptive
parents
now let's put aside for a second that
her buddy matt gates
is like really an adoptive parent to
that kid nelson i think his name is
maybe maybe that's a danger with matt
gates let's ignore that for a moment
um and see what she had to say on her
very strange podcast so let's talk about
children children are in the greatest
danger in america today
because tradition of guns right i mean
i'm sure she's going to say this there's
more school shootings than ever all
family values are being destroyed oh
oh
the idea that mom and dad together not
not fake mom and fake dad but biological
mom and biological dad
can raise their children together and do
what's right for their children um
raising them to be to be confident in
who they are their identity their
identity is they're they're a a child
you know made
by god right let's talk about um nothing
increases the confidence of kids
than being told their parents are fake
and not that good right i mean that'll
really set kids up for success so
the entire
point of this is
certainly homophobia and probably
transphobia as well so what marjorie is
really pointing to here is
uh gay parents where maybe one parent is
biologically related to the child and
one is not
um adoptive couples right just like a a
gay couple
or a lesbian couple
um and i guess because she says
non-biological even heterosexual couples
i guess are a problem because if it's
not biological it's bad according to
marjory taylor green
certainly transgender parents of all
kinds i i can only imagine even a
biologically related transparent
marjorie taylor green would say is no
good stepmoms and stepdads certainly
must be bad based on this idea foster
parents probably also terrible and then
guardians and caretakers of all kinds
like when a kid dies or whatever that
that they're all dangerous they're all
extraordinarily dangerous so what do
they want
do they want kids to suffer no they want
moms to suffer that's really it i think
the kids suffering they're indifferent
to but it's the moms if i mean listen if
you have uh
non-pro what do they call it
non-procreative sex
and there's a pregnancy
you've got to suffer as a parent that's
really important now there's two sides
to this stuff okay there's the
cartoonish nuts with their podcasts like
marjorie taylor green but then there's
the underlying policy ideas that they
want to push
and you know where this is going they
they're laying the groundwork they did
it they made it clear after roe v wade
was overturned by the supreme court
gay couples they don't want to be able
to legally adopt
they started with abortion
gay rights are on the chopping block
they're already talking about
overturning uh the decision that banned
bans on same-sex marriage effectively
legalizing effectively legalizing gay
marriage nationally
there it's all on the chopping block and
meanwhile consider the absurdity that
they say don't abort will adopt your
kids
well but actually
when when kids are with parents that
aren't biologically related that's bad
so is adoption good or bad is it worse
than abortion or better than abortion
they don't want people to have abortions
and now they don't want the wrong people
to abort
if only there was a way
to prevent unwanted pregnancy before it
even got to the point of a pregnancy
then we would have a solution oh we have
that and that that's also something that
they're against it's been widely studied
and when you go to them they
talk in circles they talk past you they
ignore they come up with well that's not
actually done the right way because we
know really good study done out of st
louis
you
divide
young people in particular
into groups where one group gets nothing
this is your control group
another group gets free access to
contraceptives
another group gets
access to comprehensive sex education
and then your fourth group gets both the
access to the contraceptives and
comprehensive sex education who do you
think has the fewest unwanted
pregnancies it's the last group
the group with the access to
contraceptives and the sex ed why don't
they want it because of their strict
father morality they have a belief that
okay fine maybe that would work to
reduce pregnancy but if you have
non-procreative sex particularly out of
wedlock as they love to say isn't that a
beautiful term you're locked wedlock
um
then you deserve it you deserve you
deserve to be forced to carry a
pregnancy to term that's fundamentally
their belief it's not about well
abortion adoption whatever no no no it's
about you got to behave
the way they believe
jesus wants you to behave even if you
don't care about that particular
religion or any religion that's what
they want
there is um
more and more information
coming out
about a black man
who was awaiting a kidney transplant who
was beaten by hospital security
the man has sadly died
but we are going to tell you the story
black man awaiting kidney transplant
beaten by hospital security
the daughter of a late black kidney
patient wants justice against the
security guards who attacked and wrongly
detained him according to the saint
louis post dispatch
the shocking incident begins with huey
robinson heading back to the barnes
jewish hospital in st louis after staff
told him he left his wallet there a few
days before the patient who had stage
four renal failure got the good news he
was number two in line for a possible
kidney transplant he got his wallet he
went back to the garage and he couldn't
find his car
so he goes to the front desk he uh
and uh even a security asks a security
guard for help as he looks for his car
apparently this caught the attention of
other security guards who started
suspecting this guy's not here for
medical treatment this guy is here
looking to steal cars
guards approach robinson they grab his
arm
and um
he then allegedly asks what did i do
one of the guards tackles him and then
it all gets crazy and he gets the crap
kicked out of him and subsequently he
died it's an insane story there is
indeed surveillance footage and in the
surveillance footage you see
um a number of uh
security officers come over
and very quickly the physical
altercation begins we don't know what
was being said there
uh a third security guard comes in
they've got him pinned to the ground
and chaos ensues uh quite quickly
chaos ensues quite quickly and he was
looking for his car
he had just gotten the good news he's
second in line for a kidney transplant
and this is what happens we don't have
all of the answers yet i guess we would
say
the lawsuit alleges that huey cried out
that the guards were hurting him and at
least one of the guards responded good
according to the lawsuit the guards then
forced huey into a pair of handcuffs
it's all on video you just saw it
the document says that robinson was
taken to an interrogation room he was
asked what are you doing in the garage
the lawsuit also claims an officer used
his forearm to smash huey's head into
the wall while another threatened the
kidney patient
if one of my officers or washu officer
sees you back on this property again
we're gonna do this whole thing again
they told them because you ain't
supposed to be here
he had just been at the hospital for
four days
for treatment
for kidney problems
he was drugged in a weakened state when
security allegedly beat him up then
there was a lawsuit for assault battery
false imprisonment he later died from
his illness and his daughter wants
justice
so
there are people saying well why are you
even mentioning that it's a black man
we're mentioning it because it's yet
another one of these stories where i'll
tell you guys if you tell me uh it it
was a it was a white guy looking around
and saying hey i'm looking for my car
uh i just don't believe that three
security guards show up suspecting that
the guy is looking to steal cars i just
don't think so i just don't believe it
and i know that there's a movement on
the right that loves to say oh david
you're racist for seeing the racism
no i don't think so
i mean when when you see these stories
and it goes beyond anecdotal and it
becomes the trend it becomes the way
they go
and we featured others
it no longer is anecdotal and so that's
why the story is being described in the
way that it's being described and sadly
this man ultimately died not from
getting beat up but from his illness
we'll see where the lawsuit goes if you
look at the video if you read the story
if you look at the facts and come to and
understand it differently
let me know i want to hear from you
follow us on social media interact with
the david pakman show community see
exclusive content see when we're taking
calls live and stay up to date on other
big show announcements we post daily
find us on reddit twitter instagram
facebook discord and tick talk
i've told you before that there are sort
of like politician lies things like oh
reducing taxes on the rich stimulates
the job creators to get out there and
build businesses or something like that
it's completely untrue but it's the type
of thing that you actually have to
really do some research in order to sort
out and debunk and and counterpoint and
then there's the types of lies that
we've seen over the last six years from
the trumpian wing of the republican
party stuff like i don't know donald
trump is six foot three inches tall and
weighs 239 pounds that's an obvious lie
and speaking of that type of lie donald
trump's former doctor now republican
congressman ronnie jackson went on the
greg kelly uh reports show on newsmax
and claimed that donald trump is fitter
than 90 of people his age now it's
okay he's qualifying it by saying people
his age
but i can assure you that that's not
true and i've got the numbers to back it
up in a moment so let's listen to what
ronnie jackson
had to say here and this is the type of
lie where like why even bother why
bother with something so obviously
untrue obama and trump now you're famous
for uh extolling the health virtues of
donald trump you did so publicly and a
lot of people are like oh man you're
over doing it
but actually let's face it
he is a very unique specimen i mean
anybody can see that he is 76 years old
he has the energy of a he's unique
that's true of a 16 year old
i don't think you were
do me a favor trump has the energy of a
16 year old yet when all the other world
leaders walked around in sicily trump
was driven on a golf cart real 16 year
old energy tell us about his health if
you don't mind
no he's in great health and people
wonder like why is he so healthy because
you know he's famous he doesn't have a
really great diet and he he doesn't
exercise much uh you know than playing
golf and whatnot but
you gotta look at the you know his whole
life i mean during it throughout his
life he never drank he never smoked he
he let a pretty healthy life overall
compared to a lot of folks and so i
think that he's reaping the rewards of a
healthy life early on and he was in
great shape i mean i put him on the
treadmill and did a cardiac stress test
on him he knocked him now was the
treadmill on because just putting
someone on a treadmill that's off won't
really stress the body too much out of
the water i mean he he was in the top 10
percent of of everyone in his age i mean
he did extremely well in his cardiac
stress test and he um he just you know
he's he's in great great health to be
honest with you and you know and i
didn't overdo it greg i'll point out
that you know i was very thorough in
briefing his physical exam something we
have not seen from the doctor at the
white house right now with regards to
yep with joe biden anything could be
going on so this is not fat shaming this
is lie shaming this is livestream you
don't have to lie about everything you
can say you like trump's policy and you
can say you think trump was good for the
country and you like the way trump dealt
with putin or whatever but not lie that
trump is one of the healthiest people
his age around remember
um stress test cardiac stress test okay
there's an analysis that was done a
longitudinal analysis of cardiac stress
tests the median exercise time for men
trump's age
was seven minutes and 22 seconds for a
maximum effort stress test
does anyone in my audience believe that
donald trump could do maximum cardiac
stress
for seven minutes and 22 seconds
and remember that's the median and we're
supposed to believe trump isn't median
but that is in the top 10 percent
there are four stages to the cardiac
stress test
in among people among men trump's age
only one percent get to part four so
forget about part four
but 15 percent of men
complete part three
they're telling us trump isn't just in
the top 15 percent who would complete
the third part trump's in the top 10
meaning of the 15 percent that
get to complete part three
trump isn't even at the bottom of that
group give me a break guys it's it's
becoming north korea type stuff remember
all the things they would say about
kim jong-un and kim jong-il and with kim
jong-il it was you know he lifted a car
above his head i think that was one of
them i know that they said the first
time he played golf he played 18 holes
and got 18 holes in one um that double
rainbows like follow the guy around or
whatever that kim jong-il doesn't
defecate you know all sorts of he
created forms of energy and is also phil
yeah
it's getting to be that that to that
degree and greg kelly you know his face
should be bright red maybe it is you
can't tell because of the makeup but
this is the type of stuff that would
make north korean propaganda uh news
anchors sort of blush so absolutely
pathetic and like just lie about things
that are difficult to obviously realize
are are being lied about uh this one is
tough tough to believe
joe rogan continues this sort of like uh
turning on donald trump rogan now um
acknowledged that he believes donald
trump was regularly on
uppers during his presidency
and called him a man baby during a d a a
recent show this is interesting for a
couple reasons which i will tell you
um daily beast reporting joe rogan calls
trump a drugged out man baby the mega
popular podcaster laughed at trump's
inability to focus on anything but
himself in his latest episode
trump uh and rogan now and i guess what
we would call a feud
um
and uh rogan suggesting that trump's
energy comes from adderall called him a
man baby this was during a conversation
with comedian and frequent guest tom
segura let's take a look at this and
i'll tell you why it's interesting in a
moment well about that guy is that you
know i'm saying even when you when you
watch him as president he was full of
energy full of it every day and they
said he slept like four hours a night
he's one of those people son adderall
god do you think he's not adderall
yes
i do only because
there were multiple people who used to
work on the apprentice that were like he
was
gassed up for shoots really yeah because
he has trouble reading he doesn't he he
he would trust he would struggle to read
prompter or script when he was just
let's say sober uh-huh so they would
give him that and he would
dial in more on reading because he gets
he gets very bored they said you know
yeah he would get bored at the c.i.a
briefing in the mornings he was like i
don't want to read that there's a daily
briefing you get as president he's like
you read it and then tell me and if it's
boring so they would have to make it
more engaging for him because he would i
heard they would put his name in
briefings
multiple times to keep him interested
and then
kushner you know his son-in-law
said that he came up with a formula
uh to keep him engaged this is called
the bad news sandwich it's often done in
a lot of venues
yes because you know he obviously was
close to him and knew him well and the
formula was
um
like
two good one bad so if they were gonna
give them bad news they could go you
start with some good news
so they go this is going well
everybody's thrilled with you about this
here's a bad thing
also people love you for this
so that's how you that's how they would
tell them bad news they couldn't just go
there's a bunch of badges of course yeah
he's a man baby he's a toddler
yeah he's a toddler so there's two
things here and i think that they're
both important to mention number one
whatever you think about joe rogan and i
have been very hard on rogan we've done
at this point what 20 different
critiques of things rogan has done and
when rogan does something good we will
praise it as well there's no ideological
or emotional attachment to it or
whatever the case may be
rogan's got a lot of trump supporters in
his audience and some of them are the
kind of
they play that they're enlightened
centrists sometimes they even claim to
read books they often don't but they
claim to
a lot of them support trump but they
don't openly and brazenly do it but they
do at the end of the day they go well
yeah i mean i voted for trump because i
decided at the end of the day this that
the other thing
it is important
and it is impactful
particularly when the reports are
trump's going to announce his 2024 uh
president candidacy for president for
the primary anyway very soon
it is important that
the culturally conservative audience of
rogan
not everybody i know there's liberals
who listen to rogan i watch some
episodes sometimes
um the culturally conservative people in
rogan's audience start to see
that alpha male rogan
is laughing at trump man baby not a
particularly alpha thing to call a guy
right it's quite beta in fact by their
nomenclature and standards
that's a good thing and it's a good
thing for people in rogan's audience to
see that
the problem is rogan supports ron
desantis for 2024 at least he said
he likes desantis he would vote for him
likes him i forget the exact wording but
it was
almost an endorsement uh but saying he
would be a great president
so
one element is simply assuming that this
isn't all
deliberate in order to prop up desantis
as a calculated thing maybe it is maybe
it isn't but even if it's not
that the criticism is all contextualized
by
rogan likes desantis who's like an even
more dangerous donald trump so
is this a good thing in the net or not
is this sort of like a de facto offense
for desantis i don't know
trading trump for desantis as president
if you said to me
either trump or desantis will be
president who do you want it to be
i think trump's less dangerous
because although he's dumber he gets
less done he's so unorganized and he's
so caught up in nonsense that i think he
gets less done
um
so
it's
if rogan can disabuse trumpists of
following trump and supporting trump
great and if he can do it in a way that
feels like that beta trump no i'm alpha
i'm with rogan whatever whatever it
takes right to to disabuse them of those
beliefs
but if it leads to desantis being the
next president or the nominee then we've
got some real problems and i don't know
the answer i don't know where it's going
we have a voicemail number that number
is 219 to david p
here's a voicemail
related to
what we talked about yesterday regarding
gavin newsom i said if newsome runs for
president they will go after him for
having been married to donald trump's uh
or married yeah to donald trump's now
wife kimberly guilfoyle donald trump jr
that is and here's a caller who says
democrats got to turn that around
hi david this idea that guilfoyle dated
newsome is bad for newsome yeah i think
is a perfect example of what's wrong
with
uh messaging from democrats okay it's
bad for trump
what they could do is say guilfoyle
is you know was dating this flaming you
know liberal that wants
uh
you know all these liberal things so
therefore it's not a problem with gaza
newsom that he was dating her it's a
problem with trump jr is he a real
conservative he's a real american is he
really someone for you or is he just
this phony that dates uh liberals uh
uh when you're not looking it's a
perfectly fine analysis but donald trump
jr at least for now isn't running for
anything and by the way
it's not an attack that would work on a
republican candidate
if donald trump jr ran for something and
then someone came out of the woodwork
and said hey you know what um don jr
he's really a left winger he's married
to this super left kimberly guilfoyle is
like now nobody believes kimberly
guilfoyle is left maybe she was before
but she's clearly not now she spoke at
cpac it will go it will get no traction
that's the perfect example
of something that will go absolutely
nowhere so they will make it a problem
for gavin news should it be one no
probably not doesn't really make any
sense
but uh that's uh you're you're thinking
logically and this is an electorate on
the american right wing that does not
think logically we have a fantastic
bonus show for you today california
leaders
wanted inflation relief for poor seniors
and yet poor seniors are being left out
again where exactly we will talk about
it on the bonus show secondly
idaho republicans have rejected an
amendment allowing an abortion when it
is necessary to save a woman's life so
you have a split on these
serious but relatively rare situations
you have some
uh anti-choice advocates saying
when it is necessary for the life of the
mother it's not actually an abortion
like it might look like the same
procedure it might have the same name a
tnc dnc
but it is a different procedure so
there's the one side is playing the
semantic game
the other side is fighting the
amendments to allow for the exceptions
and we will talk about that on today's
bonus show and lastly the department of
justice has decided it will not
prosecute a group linked to stephen
colbert's late show
after some unlawful entry arrests
related to the trump riots why
is are those arrests not happening uh
what prosecutions rather i'm sorry and
um also
what case are the right wingers making
that this is a politically motivated
decision we will have all of it on
today's bonus show how do you get access
to the bonus show very easy you go to
joinpakman.com
and you sign up
that's it
you can use the coupon code obama obama
that's with an end
to get a discount off of the cost of a
membership and you will get instant
access to the bonus show
instant access to the commercial free
audio and video streams and priority
access to david pakman show viewer town
halls
the next of which is on tuesday one week
from today tuesday july what is that 26
6 p.m eastern we will be doing the next
live town hall
we will be streaming it only on the
pacman live youtube channel this is the
other youtube channel
youtube.com
you can watch only if you prefer but
everybody's welcome to call in and our
members on the website will get priority
access
all of it when you sign up at
joinpakman.com
we will see you on the bonus show or
otherwise back here tomorrow